while we know that power lines started
that fire a different type of threat is
affecting plans to rebuild the town as
we mentioned the campfire killed more
than 80 people 27,000 people once lived
there but only about 1500 have returned
as Jonathan Vigliotti shows us a danger
in the water system is causing new
problems for residents when Jessica de
Stefano and her family moved into their
dream home last summer they never
imagined this would be their reality
19,000 buildings were reduced to ash in
the campfire melted metal plastic and
wood creating this toxic mix that
officials say six months later has
contaminated the town of paradises water
pipes they've tested positive for
elevated levels of cancer-causing
benzene if my kids get cancer in 20
years I'll never forgive myself the
irrigation district says the pipes were
contaminated either by melted water
meters or toxic air from the fire that
was sucked into the system we've tested
about 500 service lines in our district
at this point and about 30% of them have
come up with contamination paradise'
irrigation district manager Kevin
Phillips and his team are testing the
water along 173 miles of pipe line to
find out which sections need to be
replaced that alone could take two years
for now the water is unusable the
process we're facing is monumental it's
something that there's no game plan
that's been written for it it's
definitely been difficult to have a
standing home in Paradise right now at
times wish that it was gone massive
water tanks are their lifeline for
cooking and bathing how much is this
basic need cost you and your family it's
about $250 every three to four weeks and
their insurance company farmers says it
will soon stop reimbursing them for
those fill ups they said we'll get one
more refund then they're done and I said
but it's contaminated he said that's not
in our policy you know we tell our girls
no more baths try to do two minute
showers Jesse and Martin Thompson whose
home was the only one on their street
that survived the fire also rely on
their water tank we don't want to take
chances with our babies for us it was a
really big piece of mind we just wanted
some sick
jurnee securing safe water is also key
for paradise businesses and schools that
hope to eventually reopen there were
about 1,200 businesses in town before
the fire so far about 10% every opened
including two coffee shops and one
restaurant we are an essential service
and an essential part of the town to
rebuild and we take that very seriously
while cleanup crews around town are a
welcome sign homeowners know fixing the
water system is crucial to rebuilding
their community if we can't have clean
water then we can't have a talent wait
as long as it takes
yep you know we look at what has tore
this town apart but then we have to look
on the positive side we're working on
our comeback story for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Paradise California
we reached out to Farmers Insurance
Group the company says the additional
payments for the waterfall outside of
the family's coverage limitations